yeah well we're at a company called yubo
Works in a breader in the Netherlands
this is called the cruise sub seven this
is actually a seven person submersible
uh fundamentally different from Titan in
a few respects this one goes down to 300
meters it takes seven people and as you
can probably see behind me at either end
it's got acrylic windows so you can see
out uh also if you look around me it's
got digital displays uh in order to
control it this is the the joysticks
around here and also this is the way
that they can talk uh to the boat they
can send signals and if I'll just look
over here
I was described to me earlier this is
the day-to-day minute-to-minute stuff
this is when things start going wrong
this is all the emergency controls to do
with releasing ballasts to do with
oxygen controls to do with using the
batteries so I'd say this is a much more
modern sophisticated vessel but it only
goes down to 300 meters it's not built
to go down to those colossal pressures
at the depth of Titanic what this does
have in common are Titan is the
dimensions this is about the same size
as the Titan submersible that is down at
the Titanic wreck site and I can tell
you that having sat in here for a matter
of minutes it feels cramped if the hatch
above me was closed I clearly would not
have enough space to stand I probably
wouldn't have enough space to actually
sit upright now like Titan this has 96
hours of emerge agency oxygen on board
it has an enormous number of fail safes
around it as well I think if I spend a
couple of hours on board here on a
tourist Mission that's what it's
designed for I think it would feel fine
but if you spend days on board frankly
that would be a horrific Prospect